the book is called breaking out how to
build influence in the world of
competing ideas and it is about a
phenomenon I called the idea
entrepreneur and this is a new cultural
player on the scene different from a
standard entrepreneur this is a person
individual usually a Content expert
sometimes kind of a maverick or a
heterodox thinker who has a deeply felt
idea that they want to take out into the
world and their goal is not to gain some
positional power or to gain great wealth
but they want to influence how people
think and they want to affect how people
behave and they want to make some kind
of change or improvement in the world it
can be quite small in their organization
it can be in a community it could be in
the society at large it can be within a
discipline so they act usually in
beginning on their own and their tools
are themselves and their their personal
narratives their gifts of expression and
their ability to bring people into the
idea with them sometimes they if they're
very successful and are very persistent
they can go on for it for many years and
build enterprises around themselves the
enterprises are not meant to be sold or
to again gather great wealth but to
continue the idea often even beyond
their lifespan
I have studied various kinds of idea
entrepreneurs all around the world in in
different professions and different
disciplines the important thing is that
the really successful ones connect their
ideas to other ideas so you know no idea
is totally original most of us have
ideas that add to existing ideas that
bring a bit of originality that have our
own take on things and the really good
ones link into great ideas that have
come before so rather than trying to own
the idea or claim that its original to
them they say yeah I am following the
great tradition of this idea but I'm
adding this original piece
you